2018 barack obama direct quote
everything you need to know about
politics you can learn from dr seuss
but apparently he's bad now dr seuss is
bad
so here's jen sackey responding to the
fact that doctors was left
out of the presidential proclamation
because essentially a bunch of woke
academic morons
decided that dr seuss's books were
somehow spreading racism
and joe biden took that up because the
liberals have been so intimidated
by the woke left that they refused to
stand up even for iconic authors
the proclamation was written by the
department of education and you could
certainly speak to them about more
specifics about the drafting of it but
read across america day which as you're
right has not existed forever has only
been around for
a short period of time elevates and
celebrates a love of reading
among our nation's youngest leaders and
the day is also a chance to celebrate
diverse authors whose work and lived
experience reflect the diversity of our
country and that's
certainly what they uh what they
attempted to do or hope to do
uh this year okay so meanwhile over at
the
universal islands of adventure in in
florida
they're now talking about removing an
exhibit for if i ran the zoo
because it's no longer going to be
published so there's something called
seuss landing over at universal studios
we must not allow people to see the
the tufted mazurka right these fake
creatures that that
zeus created we we definitely cannot
allow people to see
all the bizarre creatures from if i ran
the zoo because i don't know kids might
then go look at the book and they might
see a portrayal of an asian person that
looks stereotypical and then
they might i don't know go and hurt an
asian person all of this based on zero
on nothing
also they're going to get rid of a gift
shop called mulberry street store which
comes from and to think that i saw it on
mulberry street which was again only his
breakthrough book
now the defense is from the liberals
here are the part here that's that's
truly telling
okay because again up until five minutes
ago dr seuss was one of the
uncounselables
the fact is politically speaking dr
seuss was not on the right he was on the
left
i mean he was so uncancelable that
michelle obama was dancing with dr seuss
characters
and while she was while she was the
first lady of the united states here she
was dancing
with doctors who's characters look right
there next to her there's a picture of
the cat in the hat
and all the kids are wearing cat in the
hat outfits including you can see in the
front row some black kids wearing black
wearing cat in the hat hats
but i guess they don't understand that
they are contributing to their own
subjugation we have to cancel cat and
they have too here's michelle obama just
a few years ago dancing with dr seuss
characters
hi hi captain oh my god that's so racist
there's the cat in the hat welcome to
the white house you excited to
hear this new wonderful book by dr seuss
yeah i can't believe she's participating
racial subjugation this morning before
he got on a helicopter
the president he'd love we love dr seuss
in our house
god this is so racist i mean first of
all they're i mean they're doing the
limbo i mean all of this is just
all of this just racially insensitive
and all those black kids who are
celebrating dr seuss they're
all those kids are have just
internalized their white privilege
that's all that's happened here clearly
by the way
just a quick note the national education
association which is busily canceling dr
seuss
some of their recommended books for
small children include i am jazz
in which children learn that they can be
members of the other sex right in which
a boy is treated as a girl
and this is considered a wonderful
wonderful thing and jacob's new dress
which encourages children to crossdress
which is really really great
so we cannot have books from 1940 that
include
a stereo stereotypical cartoon of an
asian person
but we can definitely be encouraging our
kids to read anti-racist baby by ibra
max kennedy which encourages
people to think in racist and racially
essentialist ways
and also we can encourage our three and
four-year-olds to cross-stress and or
choose their own gender
yes our society might be completely
effed it might be completely left and
it's the liberal defense of this that's
truly astonishing
again as i've been saying for a long
time here in the future of american
society the fate of american society
does not rest with conservatives
it rests with people in the middle it
rests with people in the middle who
might consider themselves
good-hearted liberals a people who might
be in favor of a little bit more
government interventionism or who don't
follow politics all that closely
are those people going to just go along
with the world crowd because the woke
crowd is the loudest and the most
annoying and the most irritating or are
they going to stand up
are they going to provide a
full-throated defense of individual
rights
the time for apathy is over here and
people
how could why are you making a big deal
out of dr seuss because you're taking
iconic figures and canceling them and
then you play this little gaslighting
mind game where it's like how dare you
pay attention to us
completely destroying children's
childhoods by suggesting that they can
change their gender in sex but they
can't read dr seuss how
dare you look into that why aren't you
more worried about other things
because that's the thing to worry about
gang i'm mostly worried about the kind
of country my kids grow up in
and how i and how i'm able to raise my
children
that is my chief concern in life as a
parent and you are trying to
reindoctrinate my kids into values you
hold dear by getting companies to cancel
books that i like reading to my kids
because you know better for my kid than
i do
and then you claim that i should not
feel imposed upon i should not you are
literally imposing on me
by banning me from doing things and yet
i should not feel imposed upon
i mean this is this is utter madness and
people mainstream liberals are defending
this of course
and we'll get to that in just one second
so let's take some examples of
mainstream liberals and their defenses
of this kind of stuff
ezra klein right the vaunted ezra klein
formerly of vox.com now of the new york
times because there's only failure
upward
in the world of the left-wing media so
ezra klein he tweeted out
uh an article from his old
publicationbox.com why fox news is
having a day-long meltdown over dr seuss
it says a lot about the modern gop that
biden and the democrats are about to
pass a 1.9 trillion dollar bill with
dozens of long time liberal policies
and what's really generating the heat on
the right is some nonsense about dr
seuss
number one it ain't nonsense book
burning is not nonsense
canceling books is not nonsense that
what do you think is a
more fundamental value i care deeply
about the national debt i've been
railing against this garbage 1.9
trillion dollar bill that is
unsupportable by fact or economics
for as long as joe biden's been
proposing it and to make the brief case
against that 1.9 trillion
plan once again here's the case
according to the most liberal
institutions the united states is going
to experience about a 450 billion
gdp shortfall this year due to covet the
bill is 1.9 trillion dollars
so four times that that large that bill
also happens to include
barrels of pork barrels and barrels and
barrels of pork for the teachers unions
and for a variety of states that have
blown out their own spending there's a
study that came out yesterday from the
brookings institute a left-wing
institute that found that california did
not even lose tax revenue last year and
yet we are bailing them out with tens of
billions of dollars from federal tax
coffers
money that no longer exists and that we
are borrowing from the future okay so
there's your case against that now
which is more important to me bad public
policy when it comes to taxing and
spending which has been endemic to both
parties and has been the curse
of the american republic for as long as
i have been alive or the complete and
wholesale destruction of children's
innocence
by a bunch of woke who have
decided that it is deeply important to
remove content that my kids want to see
because maybe just maybe there will be
somebody woke enough to inform them
the content is racist what do you think
has more of an impact on my daily
life the spending that's been going on
every day and that is a problem and a
persistent problem and it shows no signs
of going away or the complete
vitiation of american culture
particularly aimed at children
i think we can tell so yes it's
important to ezra klein and you know
it's important
that's why the left keeps doing it it's
unbelievable the left plays this trick
they do something
utterly fringe and utterly crazy and the
right reaction they go why are you even
it's a crazy thing why are you even
reacting to it
i mean sure what do you even care that
we're saying that boys are girls and
girls are boys
i mean there's a budget problem it's
like well
you know what's more important that boys
are not girls and girls are not boys
and that has an impact on my life
because i don't trust you to let this
remain a fringe issue
because guess what five seconds ago you
were talking about
getting rid of books that that you
didn't like that were actually racist
and now you're talking about just
getting rid of mainstream doctors books
that have never actually been
interpreted by any sentient human being
as racist
and so you just found a bunch of experts
at college who have no actual jobs
to push the notion that this stuff has
to be removed from the public square
okay so you got ezra client saying we
got bigger things to worry about
then you have mark harris okay so mark
harris
is the is a writer and columnist for new
york magazine and vulture
and he and he tweeted out i read a lot
about theodore geisel dr seuss and his
politics when i was working on five came
back
and there's not a doubt in my mind he
would have thought all the people at fox
news suddenly taking him up as a cause
are the world's biggest a-holes
well there's no question dr seuss was on
the left on the political left
also he would not have thought that we
were the world's biggest a-holes you
thought we were the second biggest
a-holes after people who think it's okay
to burn his books
probably if i had to just make a guess
and listen to mark harris's
justification for this
geisel was a fascinating and remarkably
non-defensive man who deplored racism
and was also capable of recognizing
where he himself had aired
so the blowhard right should stop
panicking there are still 39 zeus books
left
the trump library will be fine there are
still
39 seuss books left well guys i mean
it's not a book burning if there are
other books
come on i mean that bonfire out there
where they're just burning copies
of books there are a lot of other books
i mean in germany when there are those
all those pictures of you know books
being burned is that a big deal there
are other books in germany everybody had
a copy of mineconf that was a book that
was in everybody's house
book burning isn't bad so long as it's
the right books you see according to
liberals so long as the right books are
getting burned
that is perfectly okay in fact it is
recommended and by the way dr seuss
wasn't fully cancelled we're only
burning some of his books sure the cat
on the hat might be nuts but
don't worry about the slippery slope
just recognize that we're only gonna we
are only gonna burn the books today that
we wanna burn today and then if you ask
them what books are you going to burn
tomorrow like well we'll have to see
yeah we know we know okay meanwhile you
have cnn's chris chiles remember these
are members of the press
who would have thought honest to god who
would have thought that the biggest
advocates for restricting freedom of the
press
and restricting freedom of speech in
america would be members of the press
who saw that one coming
on their bingo card on their woke
idiotic left wing bingo card who saw
that one coming
because that's where we are okay where
we are right now
is that the press have decided they want
to see fox news and oann
and newsmax d platform they want to see
daley wire basically taken
off of facebook they want to see social
media crack down on anybody on the right
they'd love to see podcasts taken down
they want to go after joe rogan they
want to go after this podcast
and they want to go after all those
things because those are competition
members of the press
openly stumping for companies to remove
their service
abilities from people they disagree with
and now you have members of the press
who are only arguing in favor of book
burning because that's what this is
when you take books down and you make
them unavailable anymore that is the
equivalent of book burning the purpose
of a book burning is to make the book
unavailable anymore because it has been
burned
okay so we are now engaged in digital
book burning so chris chaliza
the the doltish columnist over at cnn
he has a piece today titled why
republicans think dr seuss said mr
potato head
can save them he says
liberals are trying to cancel long
church cultural touchstones that is the
message for republicans
solely because it doesn't comport with
their preferred vision for america
yes that is in fact our our argument
that you're trying to cancel all the
cultural touchstones because you have a
utopian vision for what the world should
be
and anything that stands in your ways an
obstacle so you burn it correct
that is it that is a proper assessment
of our argument he says if you look
back at what has truly animated
conservatives in the months since trump
lost the election
it's consistently been less about policy
and far more about this idea that
democrats are trying to rid the country
of our cultural icons
well i mean yes you literally spent the
summer cheering on people burning down
cities nicole hannah jones author of the
1619 project cheered the fact
that these city burnings were being
called the 1619 riots
people were literally being iconoclastic
tearing down statues of george
washington
of abraham lincoln of a guy who's an
abolitionist
fighting for the north at like the
wisconsin state house
so yes we are worried about you
vitiating and destroying american
history yes we are worried about all of
that
now on tuesday morning says chris
chaliza at cnn comes word that six
doctors who spoke would no longer be
published by the company that owns them
because they quote portray people in
ways that are hurtful and wrong
what's remarkable about these attacks by
the right on so-called cancel culture is
that they don't even fit the description
so he says that the muppets right so the
muppets disney put a warning on some
episodes of the muppet show but they
made the episodes available
okay that's fair right that's not a full
cancellation that is just
a ridiculous attempt to contextualize
humor it's stupid
but it's not a full cancellation that's
true or potato head that's not a full
cancellation because mr potato head and
mrs potato head will remain characters
okay that too is fair it's an idiotic
thing to suggest that
that children are going to be deeply
harmed by a toy called mr potato heads
you have to call the overall toy potato
head
in honor of brian stelter but this is
the line that gets me so christian lisa
says it's not cancelled culture the
muppets they're still available
potato head that's not canceled culture
that's still available or dr
seuss while six of his books will no
longer be published the remaining three
dozen or so will still be on bookshelves
that isn't a cancellation
one of those things is not like the
others one of those things just doesn't
belong so you've named three examples
there okay two of those examples the
thing didn't go away
in one of those examples the thing went
away and you're still saying it's not
cancelled culture you're still saying it
wasn't cancelled
except that it was literally canceled
and unavailable and selling for 1500
bucks on amazon
so what is chris chaliza's conclusion
what is happening in all three of these
most recent instances
is that the culture is changing changing
to incorporate more views from more
varied perspectives not just the
opinions of what
white people white people
the ultimate insults quiet people
you have to pronounce the h before the w
or it doesn't sound right white people
and mostly men men with their
penises sometimes think is acceptable or
not
change is of course scary do you see
this do you see this it's
unreal right so chris chilis's argument
is that
let me just read these two sentences
back to back okay that conservatives
have argued liberals are trying to
cancel long cherished cultural
touchstones
solely because it doesn't comport with
their preferred vision for america and
he says that's not true
that's not true because all that's
happening is the culture is changing
and it's changing to incorporate more
views
so you mean you like how the culture is
changing so it's okay to cancel things
so literally you are making my argument
for me christian lisa you're just
calling it change
by calling things change that doesn't
mean that the changes are good
or positive or decent or that book
burning became good today
i mean it's it's incredible so i'm
arguing that you guys are trying to
cancel cultural touchstones
because you want it to come you want the
world to comport with your perverse
vision
of expressive individualism and your
counselor argument is
well the world is changing so you're
wrong
no it is that you have a vision of
society i disagree with your vision of
society
i'm not trying to cancel you you are
trying to cancel everybody who you
disagree with
and all of their work change does not
equal cancel
says chris julius except when it does
except when the change literally
involves taking books off the shelves
and or pressuring companies to do the
same
then it does change and evolution in our
culture and our society is both
necessary and unstoppable
the idea we always have had everything
right or we can't always be growing
closer to a more perfect union is not
only narrow-minded but fundamentally
anti-american you see not to remove the
books as anti-american now
you see chris joliza crystal julies is
making the argument that if you don't
stand in favor of digital book burning
this means you are anti-american because
change is american you say
do you see the ideological perversion
that is happening in front of you
should i be upset that there's an entire
wing of american society that now argues
that you can justify the basic violation
of individual liberty
and free speech and you can start
burning books because change is good
you know who has said that same thing
every fascist in human history has said
that same thing
there has never been a fascist who said
that he is doing something
in order to do a bad thing no one ever
believes they're doing something in
order to do a bad thing
this is why we have neutral principles
like individual rights but
he is saying well you know sometimes
change overrides individual rights and
to oppose that
would be fundamentally anti-american
chris chiliza unbelievable and then you
have that same
sentiment from philip bump over the
washington post his argument
is that if you oppose the cancellation
of if i ran the zoo this is because
you're a racist and you agree
with racism so his article's such a
giveaway philip bump again
this guy is the media columnist the
politics and media columnist over at the
washington post again
members of the press are super on board
with destroying everything they disagree
with they are the they are the
cheerleaders
for ideological authoritarianism here
here's what philip bump writes quote my
four-year-old son recently received some
books a family member had sent us a
thanksgiving present
yes recently but this is not a story
about the us postal service
it is instead about the way in which
stated concerns about canceled culture
can serve as speckle
for frustrations over a changing world
this is the key word the ch
if you just keep saying change change
change right as in like barack obama
hope and change if you just keep saying
change over and over and over that
allows you to override individual rights
if you just keep saying change over and
over and over that means you can burn
books
isn't that exciting so here's philip
bump one of the books he sent was dr
seuss if i ran the zoo
a book i had as a kid and that i
remembered fondly in it a young boy
imagines what he do with the local zoo
where he in charge it's zeus so the boys
conjurings are wild weird creatures
whose names rhyme with their points of
origin
okay so just know quickly that his
recollection of the book
is that it was charming that he
remembered it fondly
at no point here did he say yes that led
me down my path to becoming a white
nationalist and trying to murder asian
people
you notice he doesn't say that anywhere
because it's not true
right so he read this as a book as a boy
and then he wanted to read it to his
kids
and at no point did it occur to him that
the book was racist but
now he knows it's racist and that means
that his kid
will presumably come out a vicious
racist or not or maybe not
maybe this is all perfectly harmless
because you can't name the
harmless means not harmed right no one
can demonstrate a harm here
in a court of law in order to receive
some sort of settlement you have to
demonstrate
damages no one can demonstrate the
damages here because they don't exist
they didn't happen to philip bump but
he's afraid what is he afraid that if
his kid reads
a dr seuss book that his kid might come
away a vicious racist
i sat down to read it with thomas and
rambled along in rhythm then i turned
the page to the african island of yurka
on which lived it
on which lived to be tufted mazurka in
the zeus's drawing the bird thing is
perched on a pole being held by two
caricatures of african men
that are so obviously and immediately
racist that it was almost breathtaking
it would be like watching an interview
with tom hanks in which he started
suddenly
casually dropping racial slurs a
grotesque act
accentuated by astonishments at the
source this was dr seuss the benchmark
for authors of children's book
and here are the racist caricatures he
drew
wow wow
[Applause]
if i ran the zoo as one of six zeus
books that will soon be out of
publication a decision made by seuss's
state given it's obvious racist imagery
again racism doesn't require intent
anymore and it doesn't even require
effect anymore
it's just what you say is racist right
normally
in order for a thing to be racist it has
to either have a racist effect
or a racist intent right it can be
insensitive
but for you to call something racist
requires either intent or effect as a
general rule
not so here philip bump who's never
affected by this book is a child now has
decided
that the book must be banned it must be
banned because he
was personally offended on behalf of
people he is not
this is just it's ridiculous so what is
his idea here the idea is that if you
defend
if i ran the zoo this means that you are
in favor of racism of course
the answer is that people who perceive
criticism of casual racism of the past
is criticism of their own behavior
or as a reminder of how the world around
them is changing
it's that seuss is a benchmark for a
particular sort of american upbringing
calling out seuss's infrequent racist
imagery is therefore an attack on that
view of american identity
it's a short hop from here to rhetoric
demanding we make america great again
so you're a trump voter if you don't
want these books burned
and again the basic idea here is that
you are a racist
unless you agree that dr seuss was a
racist
and unless you are in favor of the book
burning
seuss's caricatures are hurtful
anachronisms are they hurtful really
who's heard
what's more until a few weeks ago my son
didn't know this book existed so where's
the harm and he's not seeing its images
oh boy oh boy what a case that is until
a few weeks ago my son didn't know this
book existed so what's the harm in him
never being educated
i could say the same about virtually all
aspects of information
i don't want my kids to be educated
about your crappy left-wing views
my kids have never been exposed to that
so why are you insisting they'd be
exposed to your crappy left-wing views
and in fact why is it your business what
my kids see or do so you're libertarian
when it comes to you
but you're but you're an authoritarian
when it comes to everybody else and
you're
and we're racist this is this is what
liberalism has become
facts don't care about your feelings and
it's a fact that the ben shapiro show is
the largest conservative
podcast in the nation be sure to hit the
subscribe button to stay up to date on
all of our content